Okay,
so more today about the lore of acid
derivative acids and acid derivatives,
which you'll find in chapter 17,
18.
We'll get on maybe at
the end to chapter 19,
but probably that's for Friday.
Okay.
At the end last time we were
talking about uh, having, uh,
an r minus that isn't organic metallic
molecule react with an acid and showed
that of course the first thing
it does is act as a base,
not as a nucleophile
and pull off the Proton.
But even at that stage it's possible to
for another one to come in and add to
the carbon oxygen double
bond to give this dye salt.
And then when this is hydrolyzed, at
the end of the day, you get a ketone.
So you can convert an
acid to a ketone that way.
But it's difficult because uh,
sometimes it's not possible
to do it in two stages.
Here you stopped at the,
at the dye lithium salt,
then you got rid of the r minus when
you added acid and got the ketone.
But in the case of using hydride rather
than our minus as the base nucleophile.
Again, you first make the salt,
but the second time around, uh,
you can get the aluminum also
is the salt of the oxygen.
And when you have that, it's possible.
That's not a bad leaving group.
It's better than the old lithium,
the Oh aluminum so that it's possible
to do an elimination reaction where the
electrons of the lithium oxygen bond or
the oxygen and I can help push out the
aluminum, oxygen and ion. So that in situ,
well while you're doing the reaction,
it forms the Aldehyde bear in mind in
the first step in the first reaction when
we use the alcohol lithium,
we got the carbon eel group back only
after adding acid here at forms again,
while the reaction is going on.
And of course aldehydes or reactive
with literally Mulloon and hydride.
So you don't stop at the carbonyl,
you go all the way to the alcohol,
adding two H's.
Uh,
now we'll see a little bit later
or ways to try to control that.
Now decarboxylation is another, uh, uh,
interesting reaction of carboxylic acids.
And in particular of dialysis,
like melodic acid, which has two, uh,
two acid groups attached to the same
carbon. This is the scheme that, that,
uh, Mitsui Nobu used in his
paper to talk about, uh,
making the compound at the bottom
right that we discussed, uh, uh,
Dave last time or the time before that.
Now remember he first,
he got this compound by forming that
carbon carbon bond and it has two esters
and a CN triple. But we said that
it was possible to convert the, uh,
the ester into an acid.
We'll talk about this a little bit more
and the other Esther into an acid and
the cyanide also the NIH
trial group into an acid.
Now I've drawn that asset
at an interesting cotton
formation here because you
see a possibility this doesn't
happen when you have the an eye on.
But when you have the,
the protonated carboxylate,
then it's possible to do
and you have to have them.
It's possible to do this reaction.
So you use these electrons to form a
bond to that hydrogen. These go here,
these go down here. What's the
product at the top from this cycle?
Can you see what it is?
Yeah,
what did the carbon at the top become?
Carbon dioxide. Right? So,
so you have co two that'll fly off.
It's a decarboxylation and you're
left with this, which is an Ian.
All right?
And of course that can undergo
an alloy rearrangement to the,
to the ketone form of the enormity
and the h go on here, right?
And then you have the product.
So that,
so when you have to a carboxyl
groups on the same carbon and,
and it's protonated so that you can do
this cyclic mechanism to transfer the
proton,
then you can easily lose co
two and do a decarboxylation.
Okay. But there are other ways
to do decarboxylation from acids.
The Co two can be a leaving
group also from Xco,
two minus where x is something that can
tolerate a negative charge or from the
RCO too radical.
So for example,
carbonic acid though that hydrate
of CO2 got gotten under can,
uh, if it, uh, it's an acid, it's also
a base. So if you, if you get this,
uh, form, then you can see how it
can undergo the decarboxylation.
So that's just the reverse.
If the hydration of co two,
so carbonic acid and CEO to go
back and forth, uh, Civil Elisa,
that's a case where the x can can leave
with the, uh, with an unshared payer.
Okay.
Or Car Bam make acid where the,
where it's nitrogen that does the trick
and you can see the same kind of thing
to get a decarboxylation,
right.
Or we actually mentioned last semester
already a Colby electrolysis where it's a
free radical that does it.
So you start with a carboxylate an ion,
but you do an oxidation to remove an
electron from it, which then makes this,
this free radical. But that free
radical is fabulously unstable.
When r is an eal group
and it undergoes this,
a shift of the electron, single
electrons, it's a radical process,
which is fast.
Even at four Kelvin,
you can't see Ya ESR
spectrum of this thing.
Even at that very low and immediately
lose a CEO too and gives the stable that
the free radical, even if it's not a
particularly stable, free radical. Uh,
so you remember Colby used that,
uh,
unbeknownst to him to make
r two R two was ethane.
Remember he thought he had
made the methyl radical,
but once molecular
weights were determinable,
it turned out that he actually had
the dimer, uh, ethane. And in fact,
that reaction can work fairly well
synthetically to take two acids,
knock out two CEO twos and
have the rs come together. Uh,
that was done in 1848, but in 1973, uh,
they got a 50% yield by doing electrolysis
that generates this free radical by
losing CO2 from it and
the dimer was formed.
Okay. So there are examples
of decarboxylation, uh,
but also there's another
one that's interesting,
which is to treat an acid,
uh, with silver oxide,
which gives a silver salt of the acid.
Right?
Then if you treat that with bromine,
you get our br.
So you can convert a carboxylic
acid to the are to the,
to the [inaudible] bromide
with one less carbon atom.
A decarboxylation has been involved,
okay.
And it's pretty easy to see how
that would work if you react.
The salt with br to the o minus can do
a nuclear filling substitution on bro,
been with bromide leaving to give this,
uh,
to give this a bro
brominated intermediate.
But now if you have a
free radical in there,
it can attack the bromine to form the
RBR bond and generate this radical,
which is we've already seen
immediately lose a CO2 and give.
So we have a free radical chain
that allows, uh, this, uh,
brominated acid to become our br.
Now this, this reaction to
convert an acid to a, an Lpo,
bromide is called the Hunt's Deeker
reaction for a sort of curious reason.
It seems to me in between 1936 and 1944,
uh, the hunts dickers husband
and wife, uh, published,
I think something like six patents for
doing this and one paper in the open
literature. Right? But in fact,
the same reaction had been done in
1861 and published in a leading German
Journal and Nolen,
uh,
by Alexander Porphyria of Bora Dean
who was obviously much earlier than the
hundred stickers. This
is his, uh, his, uh,
Tulum in Saint Petersburg.
And notice that it doesn't have anything
about doing this reaction on it cause
he was not only a chemist, he was
also a musician. Uh, so can you those,
I know some of you are good musicians.
Can you see what this
line is up at the top?
What is it?
Paula. Betsy and dances by Bora
Dean from Prince Igor. And in fact,
although he didn't get any recognition
in terms of the reaction being named for
him, these people that came along
75 years later got their credit.
He did get a posthumous Tony
Award because that tool, you know,
Dadada Dadada Dadada is the,
is the theme of the musical Kismet.
So he came out, okay. Anyhow, okay.
But now when we think about,
so here's a way to take our CEO
too and make it into our br,
right? When you're thinking
about possibilities or synthesis,
you should think about is there,
is there a way to go the other direction
to start with our br and go to our,
to go to the acid with one
additional carbon. So can
you add a carbon to do that?
Can anybody think of a way of doing that
to take our br and substitute the br
with an acid groups, you know, to
put another carbon on the chain.
Okay,
we'll actually talk about this
some more later, but we, we,
we had shown an example that
if you have cyanide, which,
which is a nuclear file,
so you could do an sn two
reaction and put cyanide there.
But cyanide has the same oxidation
state of the carbon as the acid does.
So just treating it with
water and either acid or base,
and we'll talk about this a little
later on and he can do that.
So you can go either direction,
you can take the acid to the
bromide or the bromide to the acid.
And that's not the only way. Notice
that this involves the are being our,
plus the thing with the Lumo, the sigma
star that gets attacked by the cyanide.
But there's another way to start with Rbr,
whereas our is r minus, it's
a homo that does the, the uh,
the attacking.
So how would you convert RBR
into something that's like
our minus something that
has a high homo?
Yeah.
Under what circumstances does ar have
behave like our minus is it associated
with a high homo?
Yeah.
When it's associated with a halogen,
it's a low Lumo right. What is it?
And it's the, uh, it's the sigma star,
but how can you get the
sigma to be high energy?
Pardon me?
A greenie. Ari Agent. Okay, good. So
you, if you want our minus, you read,
make a Greenie our reagent and now you
have to react that in order to get an
acid,
what will you react it with?
What will it attack in order
to put the carbon oxygens on
Roy [inaudible]?
Yeah, sure. Carbon dioxide.
It's exactly the reverse of the
reaction we're talking about. Right?
So you bring carbon dioxide in,
you got the salt,
treat it with acid and you do it.
So there's,
there are many ways to skin these cats.
Okay,
so we're talking about acid derivatives
that we've just been talking about
acids, but acid derivatives are things
where you have some other group,
their x with an unshared
pair. Not, uh, not ooh.
Okay. So, uh,
one example that's called it an acid
derivative is a night trial that we just
talked about. Uh, another
one is a key team.
Now let's think about how these are
regarded as acid derivatives there.
As we just mentioned in the last slide,
the carbon has a plus
three oxidation level,
cause x is electronegative something
with the unshared pair there.
And in night trial it's also plus three.
So you can go between these things,
that acid just by treating
them with water. Okay.
Although you may need catalysts than
a high temperature in order to do it.
Night trials are not so easy
to, do. You remember he,
he a reflux that for 24 hours or
something like that in order, uh,
Mitsui, Nobu did in order to
do this. Okay, that's fine.
But over here the carbon is,
is plus two in its oxidation level.
It doesn't look like you're
dealing with the same thing, right?
However this other carbon is minus two
and if you add water to it and if you go
to the acid, it's minus
three plus three. So it's,
it's again no change in our
overall oxidation levels.
So you don't need an oxidizing
her reducing agent and
you can just do that with
water. So key teen will react with
water to give a carboxylic acid.
So all these things are called
acid derivatives. Okay? First,
just the word about the spectroscopy.
In fact,
I'll go in about three seconds through
the first slide cause we've already done
it in some detail.
I remember we looked at carbon eel
stretching frequencies in the IRR and saw
that aldehydes and ketones were similar,
but the amid was much lower frequency
because of the unshared pair on the
nitrogen being involved stabilized
by the carbon oxygen Pi Star.
And therefore weakening it to make it a
weak bond. But it's in the case of, uh,
but in the case of the Ester,
the bond was in fact strengthened a bit.
And in the case of acid chloride,
it was strengthened quite a bit.
And that the reason for that was that you
could get this other curious resonance
structure.
Okay,
so we already did this and
I'm not spending any time
just reminding you of it,
but the one thing I'll
talk about that's new is,
is the an hydride,
which is of course an acid derivative
where the x group that can,
that's attached to the
carbon eel is another acid.
So here we see an IRS spectrum and
here is the percent transmission.
So that's,
so this is very little light.
Getting through a strong absorption
means a means. A small number here.
And if we look in this, this region,
here's the carbon eel region,
we see that there are two peaks,
which isn't surprising because
there are two carbon eels, right?
There's one at 1819 which is very strong.
And another one at 1750
which is considerably weaker
right now to carbon eels to
IRR frequencies to IRP because that
seems to make sense except that it's
symmetrical.
Wouldn't you expect them to be the same?
Pardon me?
Asymmetrical frequency.
Okay, so they couple, right? The two,
they could either both be stretching at
the same time or one can be stretching
while the other shrinking.
And if they're close enough together,
separated only by ox one oxygen,
they can interact mechanically one another
and one of those is easier than the
other. So the normal modes,
there are two normal modes.
Both involve both of the COO bonds.
Right.
And we can understand how it
would be because if they're,
if they're in phase both
stretching at the same time,
then the light will interact
very strongly with it. Okay.
Because both of them were being stretched
by the same direction of the electric
field and the light. So, and it turns
out that that's difficult to do.
It's difficult to stretch
them both at the same time.
It's better to have one stretch when
the other shrinks in terms of energy.
So this one is hard to do.
That means it's at high frequency,
but it's quite intense
because the, the uh, the,
but they're both going the same direction.
The other normal mode would have one
going up while the other's going down.
Now if they were strictly parallel,
there would be no net interaction
to the light for that.
But if they're twisted a little
bit or splayed out a little bit,
then there will be some
interaction with light.
They won't exactly cancel one another.
And that's what happens here.
So you have a strong peak where they're
both stretching at the same time and a
week or peak where one is stretching
and the other is shrinking. Okay.
Now if you compare that
with this sick leak image,
which is another acid derivative where
nitrogen is attached to the ACL group.
And now we looked at the,
at the peaks here,
and you see a strong peak at low frequency
and a week peak at high frequency.
So it's exactly the opposite.
Can you see why it would be the opposite?
Cause now when they both
stretch at the same time,
when when one stretches
and the other shrinks,
the oxygens are moving the same direction.
So they're both in being pushed the way
light wants them to go. Right where,
so that one,
which is now,
which is now the easy one to do where
stretch one and shrink the other is now
very strong.
It interact strongly with light.
But the one where they're in
phase here is now a very weak,
they nearly cancel one another.
Okay.
So that's just an interesting
additional example of, of uh, of,
uh,
IRR coupling.
But it helps you see how you use the IRS
to interpret stuff about structure as
the weather to carbonyls are parallel
or anti parallel most of the time.
Okay. Now the Inter conversion, the
chemistry of the acid derivatives.
So the idea is that some nucleophile
comes in and forms the bond and then the
other one leaves day.
So that's a substitution.
But of course it involves a tetrahedral
intermediate. It's not like sn two.
You actually have an association
to give it in a stable,
intermediate followed by dissociation.
So it's not a pentavalent
transition state.
It's a tetrahedral Tetra
Vaillant carbon intermediate.
Now, which group will leave from
that intermediate x or y? Well,
there's a hierarchy of these things.
The easiest thing to leave as chloride
than carboxylic acid than an alcohol and
I, and then nitrogen and I.
And so, uh, and you can, uh,
you can see why this would be why so?
Because that's the order of stability
of the Anti Ins, right. As, as,
as exemplified in the PKA.
So if you could make
the most energetic one,
the top one. Yeah, the acid chloride.
Then by adding the others
successful successively,
you could make it into any of
the other three or the next one.
The asset and hydride into,
in either of the other two or
the ester into the amid or,
and so on.
So the important thing is to get up at
the top of the ladder at the beginning.
And you can do that the same way
you'd converted alcohol to do RCL.
You can get rid of the acid to the
acid chloride by using SOCL too.
And as I was saying, out of
order before the, the, this,
this order of the hierarchy
is clear because of the pks,
they're in the order of the
stability of the Anti Ions, right?
But it's not just the stability of the
anti ions that makes them have that order
because as we saw before,
you get resonance stabilization of the
electrons that are on why that is the,
the, uh, whatever this group is here,
chlorine, oxygen, oxygen, nitrogen,
right is those electrons are stabilized
by the vacant orbital here as denoted by
these resonance structures.
So even if you didn't have the question
of the stability, the, and ions,
this stability of the derivatives would
still be the same that it likes most to
be with nitrogen because it can get the
special stability from stabilizing the
high energy electrons of the nitrogen.
It's lower. If it's an oxygen,
it's still lower if it's a carboxylate
group because although it's an oxygens
unshared pair, as in the case
of alcohol, those electron,
that electron pair on that oxygen has
already stabilized by its own Carbonell
group. So it's not as available
for being stabilized by,
by the one here. So it's not, so
this one is not as stable as that.
This one is not as stable as that.
And what that means is you don't have to
do this with base in order to get these
anti ends in order to have
this reactivity scale.
You could do the same thing if you,
if you had acid catalyzed and we've
already seen it in the case of Fischer
esterification where you convert,
uh,
an out where now it's a question
of alcohol and water. That is,
are you going to put on Oh, are or are
you going to put on o h right. And we've,
we've gone through the acid catalyzed
and mechanism of Fischer esterification
which converts Oih to Orr
or o r o h and the equal.
And you can also do transistor effication.
You can take one Esther and a different
alcohol and have the o our prime replace
or double prime or something like that.
You could go back and forth
from one Esther or the other.
But the equilibrium constant for this
acid catalyzed processes about one.
There's not much difference
among the different ares,
but you make it go the way you want in a
Fischer esterification by using the law
of mass action, you put in a whole bunch
of alcohol, then you get that Esther.
Okay.
Or are you put in a whole bunch of water
and then you get the carboxylic acid,
right?
So the going back and forth between a
alcohol between Esther and acid also is,
is very much like these
transistors applications.
But if you use base, it's
a different story, right?
So you can have a hydroxide come in
and or minus go out. That's fine.
And it looks like it should be, uh,
an equilibrium constant of about one.
But in fact,
this reaction has a special
name [inaudible] and it has
an equilibrium constant,
much greater than one.
Now,
why should there be a difference between
o r and o h? An enormous difference.
It's because this isn't
the end of the line.
That O r minus that disappeared can
get back in the act. In what way?
Okay,
Sebastien. Right? This is it.
This is not called an acid
for nothing, right? So it can,
it can transfer the
proton to the or minus.
And now that's very favorable because
the pka of the acid is about five.
The PKA of a typical alcohol is about
16 so they differ by 11 orders of
magnitude.
That means the equilibrium constant is
about 10 to the 11th when you take factor
in that you,
that you don't stop at the acid but go
to the anti end of the acid and to the
alcohol. Okay? Now,
why does this thing have a special name?
Saponin effication this particular,
uh,
substitution reaction because you have
these things called triglycerides,
which are long chain acids,
right?
Attached as Esther's to a
three carbon unit, right?
Do you know what else you call
those things besides triglycerides,
but fats? Okay, so that's fat.
And if you treat fat with lie,
you're doing something that's
been known through Millennia,
right?
Because lie is what you get when
you take the ashes from a fire and,
and filter water through it, right?
And then evaporate the water.
You know what you get?
What lie is?
Yeah,
it's potassium hydroxide.
Okay?
So you treat it with Koh and you
have this reaction take place.
So you get carboxylic acids,
long chain carboxylic acids,
and you get alcohols on all those,
those three.
So these long chain fatty acids,
the salts of them,
the potassium salts are called what?
Yeah.
Why is it called [inaudible]?
Pontification what's Savo owner?
South Porn. Yeah. Right. It's so, right.
So that's how soap was made
and still is made. Right.
And that stuff is called glycerin that
try alcohol right now there's a very
interesting book about lore in the
Appalachian Mountains called the Fox fire
book.
Has Anybody seen that?
There was a movie made from
it a long time ago actually,
but a bunch of high school,
uh, uh, English class,
uh,
had the project of going out and talking
to people who knew how to do things and
then write the traditional lore.
And one of the people they talked to was
the grandmother of one of the girls who
was, uh, whose name was Pearl
[inaudible] Martin and who made soap.
And so she showed the girl, she had a big
kettle and put in Lard and put in lie.
And, and stirred it up. And, and she says,
and then there she says now
the soaps making and so on.
And so she got the soap out and she
said, you know, I can wash my hair in it.
And the girls were,
were astounded that she would wash her
hair in this stuff that came from lie.
Right.
But
she said,
I eat afraid to wash my hair in it.
She said that their lard eats the lie.
What did she mean by she? She of
course, hadn't studied chemistry,
at least I don't believe, although she
had very good practical knowledge of it,
that she knew that she could
wash her hair with this stuff.
Even though it you'd put lie in it.
The girls were dumbfounded at this.
Right. But the reason is that
the large eight, the lie,
the lie was like Aro
minus, right. PK about 16.
But this last stage that
makes the reaction go,
it makes it a Karbach slate
with the PK of only five.
So it doesn't hurt your hair. Yeah.
So there's some tradition for you
now. Uh, an interesting, uh, uh,
question is how to,
is what happens when the nucleophile is
r o minus our apartment is r minus or h
minus rather than these other things.
So I'm going to put a little bit
of this on the board and there's a,
let's see us get this up.
Put this thing over on the other screen.
Actually it's supposed to
be there. Yeah, there it is.
Okay,
so let me put this up
and
get some light here.
Yes,
yes. This no, this,
there we go.
Okay.
So what if you have
r minus
or h minus
as the nucleophile.
Okay,
so suppose we start, these are for
reactions with acid derivatives.
Suppose we use the acid chloride
then if we use hydride for example,
lithium aluminum hydride
so the alh four minus hi homo there.
Okay,
so that's good. So hydride can come
in here, put minus on the oxygen,
chloride can leave
and we get Aldehyde. Okay. But,
uh, the reaction won't stop there, right?
Because we already know that aldehydes
are reduced by lithium aluminum hydride.
So we'll go on to put two,
uh,
pardon me to put two hydrogens on and,
and make ultimately make this.
And ultimately when you add acid,
you'll get all the way to the
alcohol, not just to the, sorry,
not just to the, uh, to the Aldehyde.
So it's not just our substitution
of chloride by hydride,
but you go on all the way to the product
or if you have an al kill lithium
or an LPL magnesium bromide.
Okay.
You'd do the same kind of thing.
You get the out the, the, uh,
now would be a ketone first.
Cause this is an art group.
Yeah.
But again,
you go on and get the alcohol
having put on two new our groups.
So if that's the kind of alcohol
you want with two our groups,
there's a good to our groups have the
same kind that you can get from an Lpo.
Hey, lied then, uh, that's
a good way to do it.
Now if you do use an Ester,
yes,
I'll just write ditto.
Yes.
Right. If you, if you react it
with Alyssa, Google hydride,
you get all the way to the alcohol.
Replacing now the or minus instead of
the cl or if you use LPL lithium or I'll
kill magnesium bromide.
You all go all the way to the alcohol.
In fact on a particularly
interesting one is to use to chlorine
or two asters.
Can you see what would happen
in that case if you use,
if you react to those with
the hydride or with the uh,
or with the r minus at Lpl metal compound,
what's going to be different?
Well, if you went through,
uh, yeah, you, you, you,
you replace the chloride by r minus,
same kind of trick we're
doing here or h r h minus.
Then you replaced the other
chloride by h minus or are minus,
get an Aldehyde or a ketone and then you
do the, then you add to the carbon eel.
So now we put three groups on.
So we have a c o h at the end
with three our groups. You could
do the same thing with the hydride,
but there wouldn't be much point
in making methanol that way.
You're using expensive reagents
to make something cheap.
But if you want something that has
three of the same art groups on it,
that could be a practical
way of going about it. Okay.
It's slightly different.
Yeah.
If you're using an ami and a mid,
so suppose you is,
let aluminum hide
dried.
Now we'll get,
uh, just, uh, all this are here.
So we have Nh two
and h minus that came in right now what
we've done above is then deludes this
group that was originally there,
Louis chloride or lose. Oh,
minus R o minus. Right. But
it's a little different here
because with the aluminum
salt here,
the aluminum helps make this oxygen
a better leaving group than it would
otherwise be.
So in k instead of losing,
instead of coming like this
and losing the nitrogen,
what happens is the unshared
pair helps you lose the oxygen.
So the, the nitrogen
is not lost. It's still
there
as n a double bond.
Now
H and two h is on there.
Right?
But now that's rather like
the carbon eel group. Right?
So the h minus can get the lithium
aluminum hydride can get in the act again.
Okay.
And the product
from lithium aluminum
hydride reduction of an amid
isn't a mean.
Okay.
So now these are examples then of going
all the way to the coh carbon deals
completely gone. And if you added
two or in one case, three groups, uh,
but you might actually
want the intermediate,
you might want the Aldehyde.
So the question arises is there a
way to stop it so you can get that
intermediate product and you can do that.
You can stop by tuning.
Yeah,
the nucleophile
so that it's able to react in the first
reaction but not reactive enough to
react in the second.
Yeah.
So for example,
instead of using lithium aluminum
hydride use lithium aluminum hydride,
but that instead of having other hydrogens
on it has OT beautiful taken three
times.
Now there are two things about that
having that in place of hydrogen.
The first is that the oxygen
is electron withdrawing.
It stabilizes and ions.
So it makes the electrons here that
are going to be doing the attacking the
sigma electrons. It makes the
blower in energy at less reactive.
What else about having the tea butyl
group here would help in mitigating the
reactivity of that?
Try Tbo toxi lithium aluminum hydride
roll,
right? It's big. So it's
hard to approach. Okay. So,
so it's reactive enough to
do take the acid chloride
to the Aldehyde,
but not to take the
Aldehyde in the second step,
but it's used at very low
temperature at dry ice temperature.
Right?
So that,
that second reaction won't
happen or you can use,
uh, in a very similar, uh, situation,
a reagent called die bow.
Again, you use it at minus 78
degrees and it's, it's again,
uh, uh, an aluminum hydride.
But now again,
it has,
it doesn't have the oxygen's [inaudible]
but it has to isobutyl groups,
which again are big and help,
uh, help tame it so that one,
it could be used with the ester
and take it over to the Aldehyde
or,
uh,
another way of getting
from the acid chloride, uh,
or, uh, uh,
from the acid chloride and stopping at
the Aldehyde is to do it with h two and a
catalyst.
So the acid chloride
reduce it to put h two
on the ends of the bond.
But of course the Aldehyde
can also be reduced.
So you tame the reactivity of the
catalyst by adding a nitrogen containing
compounds. Quit on this is
called the Rosen Monday.
Okay.
Procedure.
We saw this before,
the idea of of a catalytic hydrogenation
where you make the catalyst less
reactive in order to stop it and
remember what that was way back when.
Yeah,
right.
The Lid lar catalyst where you wanted
to take a triple bond and go just do a
double bond but not from the
double bond to a single bond.
It was again a case of adding something
that would poison the catalyst.
Okay.
And finally,
just as a reminder,
okay.
It's possible to have an acid chloride
yeah.
And react it with a very,
very weak carbon nuclear file that
only will react if you soup up the,
uh,
chloride by using ALC l three to
help make that a good leaving group.
Now you can use a really weak, uh, uh, uh,
carbon nucleophile high homo on carbon,
right.
That will react to give the ketone.
But won't react with the ketone
because it's so weak here.
Or you did a special thing to
help make the chloride reactive,
but it doesn't help make the
Quito and you get reactive.
Remember what the nucleophile
is you use in this?
Okay.
An ACL chloride, ALC, all three.
What is it?
He's situation.
So you could use benzene
as the nucleophile.
We talked about it from the point of
view of something attacking benzene,
but now we're looking at it the other way.
Benzene attacking the something else,
right?
So we make the aromatic Quito on
that way by Friedel crafts isolation.
But again, it's a question where you can
do the first one but not the second one.
By tuning the reactivity of the,
of the reagents.
Okay. Now, uh,
acid base hydrolysis of RC.
Yeah.
Let me just use the other
board here for it for a moment.
And this one? No, that one.
Okay.
So we talked before about about
converting the CN two carboxylic acid.
Okay.
And we can,
we can go through acid and base
catalyzed mechanisms of doing that.
There's, it's, it's very simple. And I've,
I've got a blackboard realization of
that just to trace through it quickly.
Okay? So you have the, the,
the night trial, the CNE group,
protonate it rev a resonance structure.
They ass plus on carbon.
React that with,
so now you've got the COO bond,
lose a proton, okay, so you
have the alcohol here now,
but then protonate the nitrogen.
Now that's uh,
now we have this, but if you take a
take of base and pull off this proton,
you have the amid, okay? In other words,
this is an Al Lily curry arrangement.
It's a height, uh, uh,
hydrogen hydrogen here that goes to
the other end of this double bond,
okay? So you, so you could get
partway to the acid you get from the,
this acid derivative to this
acid derivative, the amid, okay.
But now suppose you protonate this
back again and get to this one,
which I've redrawn here and have
that carbon plus attacked by the,
by water, right? So now a second
water attacking the carbon.
Okay.
And take the Proton off here and put
it on the nitrogen and then have the Nh
three leave with the electrons.
All right?
You know this cat die and lose a proton
and now you're all the way to the
carboxylic acid. So there are two
stages of substituting water here.
First or first adding first adding water
to give the amid and then changing the
amid acid derivative
into the asset itself.
So that's acid ketalysis and I
won't spend more time on it now,
but it would be good for you
to be able to do that. Okay.
But you can also do it with
base, right? So in base you,
you attack the CN triple bond as if it
were a COO double bond and write this,
but a proton on right.
And now do the elderly curry arrangement.
The same thing we did before,
except that now instead of being
acid catalyzed, it's base catalyzed.
So we're halfway,
there were two the amid,
I have once we put the last proton
on and now we can go from the amid,
attack it and then lose the
Nh two probably after when
it's inappropriate mated
farm and we have the carboxylic acid and
drive it all the way to completion in
base as in the case of Saponin effication
by making the anti in the stable
Carbox lady and I am okay.
So they're both acid and base could be
used but it's a hard reaction to do.
It has to be heated a lot
and there sometimes people
even do it using biological
catalysts that to try to get it
down to two, a lower temperature.
Now a key teen we said was another,
uh,
another uh,
acid derivative.
So you have an acid chloride
and react it with an a mean.
We've just been talking about
reactions like this where the product,
you lose chloride add nitrogen and the
product is an amid the carbon eel with
nitrogen next to it.
But this is a special case because
there are three alcohol groups on the
nitrogen. You'll see how that
makes it special. I, Asia,
we have you put,
if you put,
if you use the nitrogen as a nucleophile
and attack and chloride leaves,
then you have n plus,
right?
Because you've used the unshared pair to
make that new bond and normally you'd,
what would you do with that?
And plus how would you get
rid of the charge north?
Normally you lose a proton from the amine.
But this time we used a try out kill.
I mean so it can't do that.
So in fact it doesn't do it right.
Instead instead of doing it
probably attack, sometimes
chloride probably leaves,
but chloride can come back and then
nitrogen leave because it couldn't become
stable by losing a proton.
So that probably goes on.
But another reaction can happen instead,
which is for the,
the nitrogen base to attack a proton here.
So you could do an elimination reaction,
lose hcl and you generate then key teen,
this funny molecule,
which is sort of an analog of co two,
right? Except instead of an
oxygen, you have ch two group here.
Now that group then can be attacked
by a nucleophile the same way CO2 is
attacked.
And now you have the nucleophile attack
and that attack and that's an analyte so
we could draw the resident's form of it,
right?
And we could put a proton on there,
right from the,
from the protonated
nuclear file and get the,
get the product right.
Plus the nucleophile and I in which
has now been able to do it to the next,
uh, key teen. Okay. So what
we've done is convert, uh,
keeped heating into an acid derivative
depending on what nucleophile we used,
right? And you can use lots of different
nuclear files. Here's for example,
taken from that, uh, Jones textbook is a,
is a sulfur as the nucleophile.
This,
they said it was done at dry
ice temperature for three
days and gave a thioester
right?
At 93% yield.
Or instead of base catalyzed like this,
it could be acid catalyzed.
So reaction with t butyl
alcohol with acids,
so the acid can protonate the oxygen,
then the oxygen,
this oxygen can attack,
right?
As a nucleophile lose the
proton and you get the TB,
the Lester 87% yield,
or you can use a nitrogen,
right? This has done an ethanol
water and it gives us 75% yield.
Of course these other things could have,
could have reacted right?
The O minus or the r h o minus could
have reacted if it were in base,
but it's probably it,
although it's not, doesn't,
isn't said so here it's probably an acid.
So it's probably acid catalyzed reaction
now then you can have a
insertions into ACL. Our bonds.
Let me just start this and
we'll finish it up next time.
So we'll talk about the first reaction.
You remember this picture?
Who's interesting in this picture
that we talked about before?
This guy here.
Remember who that is.
What did he do?
If you can't remember his name,
he made try fennel methyl, right. That's
Gomberg. So this is the same picture.
And there's buyer who was the boss of
the lab. But this is Victor Villinger.
I a Swiss who was working in the music
lab at the time and just at 1900.
So the same time that that, uh, God
Berg was making try fennel methyl,
the buyer Villinger reaction was,
was invented,
which inserts oxygen into,
uh,
an ACL bond. So let me just, uh,
do that one quickly on the
board and then we'll quit.
So what we're doing is taking our oh
bar and we're going to insert on Adam in
here to make it r
o o r right?
So change a ketone into an ester.
And the way it's done is to
react it with a per oxy acid.
All
right?
So now we have our oh minus and it's,
it is acidic.
So we'll take the old liners,
uh Oh.
Oh,
okay.
And now normally we normally,
what we think of as
these electrons come in,
okay.
And lose this group. Look,
probably lose this group,
but we don't have a leaving group here,
right?
So instead what happens
is that these electrons
come here.
Yeah.
So we have double bond o at the top are,
and now what's attached
here is, oh, this, oh.
And attached to that o is the other
r and this good an ion has left,
right?
So we ended up by inserting
an oxygen into the CR bond.
And we're, we're gonna talk
more about that next time.